hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Reason magazine
senior editor Radley Balko we are
looking at the three most egregious
police abuse videos that have come to
light in 2011 the first one we're
looking at is a Utah SWAT team that goes
in and tell us what they do well they
were actually investigating this guy's
roommate and they they pulled him over
realized he wasn't at the house but then
thought there was gonna be a meth supply
at the house so they went ahead and
raided the house anyway this this
gentleman was in the house he was
admitted meth addict and this guy you
know comes out thinks somebody's
breaking into his home apparently comes
out with a golf club and they opened
fire it's a it's a pretty disturbing and
shrewd and did they kill him yeah okay
next up is the Seattle Police Department
and the action happens off-camera what
are we listening to the policeman in the
car who's capturing the video what's he
talking about so he sees this a homeless
guy has a knife that was perfectly legal
under Seattle law this was how he made
some money he carved things out of wood
and sold them on the street and the cop
says tells him to drop the gun and I
think about six seconds expire from the
time he gets out of the car and
confronts the guy until he fires the
shots you also hear a woman say you know
why did you shoot him it was doing
anything it's stunning really in how
quickly things escalate from this widlar
sort of walking down the sidewalk kind
of minding those business minding his
own business until he's you know dead on
the sidewalk and in this case the cop
was was cleared there was a
investigation but there definitely won't
be any criminal charges against him and
then the final one we're looking at this
is uh some cops in Michigan who go into
a recording studio of a local heavy
metal musician who was taping a
recording with his band and tell us what
happens there so they get an anonymous
tip that this there are drugs in this
house and they find you know personal
used marijuana but
once they're inside they realize there's
always great equipment there and first
they actually start singing and the band
was recording something what we're
listening to is tape that the police
didn't realize that they were making you
hear them start talking about what of
this guy stuff that they want to take
through asset forfeiture is there a way
that we can quantify police abuse of
this sort I mean some of it is violent
you know it certainly in two of these
three cases I mean we're talking about
people being killed is this type of
police action on the rise well it's a
tough question I mean I think in terms
of we can certainly say that for example
the use of SWAT teams has increased
dramatically
we can look at asset forfeiture funds
and and how they've risen over the years
so that certainly is true in terms of
sort of non legal or illegal abuse I
guess I mean that's harder to quantify
just because you know it's hard to say
what what does and dust doesn't
constitute abuse right so you get a cop
gets captured on video beating somebody
after the Seattle cop for example this
homeless guy shooting I mean officially
that probably would not count as an
incident of police abuse because he was
cleared right so it's hard to tell
police departments are pretty reluctant
to track their own mistakes like a lot
of government agencies but you know if
you look if you talk to criminologist
actually they will say academic
criminologist will actually say that
it's it's getting better that actually
police departments are more professional
and they are more accountable and
transparent than they've been in the
past that doesn't mean it's acceptable
right it just means that it's better
than was in the 50s and 60s how has
technology changed things both in terms
of kind of citizen based technologies
they're going back to the Rodney King
beating which we only saw because a guy
was experimenting with his new video
camera but up through an age where we
have cell phones things like that but
also where the police are actually
surveilling themselves more how is that
bringing things to light and is it
helping yes I mean I think it's it's
great on on all accounts I think it's
great that police are monitoring
themselves with cameras and microphones
I think it's great that citizens can
also have their own cameras to keep
police accountable now I think it does
give
this perception that things are getting
worse because we're now being more aware
of police abuse I think traditionally
you know the police narrative was of
what happened was the official narrative
and that's the narrative the prosecutors
defer to it's what the judges deferred
to it's usually what juries believe and
now I mean there is this new very
powerful weapon that citizens have to
challenge that narrative and you know
sometimes video can be misleading it
could be taken out of context but it is
a very very powerful potent weapon and
it's I mean there are dozens and dozens
of cases where a citizen shot video is
actually shown that a police officer
lied on a police report so I think you
know it's holding police accountable
police officers accountable in those
particular cases but I also think it's
it's encouraging sort of best practices
in general because police now should go
out there business knowing that
everybody has a camera in their pocket
and I think that's a powerful incentive
Radley Balko senior editor of Reason
thanks for talking to us I'm Nick
Gillespie for Reason TV